hey Jen can you make sure I've been
framed hi guys I'm at camera camp I'm
I'm frame yeah you are there's a
reflection from this light on the back
wall disregard that reflection even
though I'm the camera camp you would
think this would be the most incredibly
shot beautiful video that you've ever
seen but it's not and sitting on the
floor in my hotel room this is where we
are yeah so what's really cool is this
event is put on by Sony and there's a
ton of other influencers and
photographers and just really really
cool people and they're also letting you
check out and rent gear for the week
what I'm filming on right now is the a7
r3 I've actually never used this camera
before and I'm shooting on a 12 to 24
lens and it's really cool because it's
super wide angle watch did I did i zoom
in or out can you zoom me back into how
I had it not you but I've got a lot of
things to show that so there's all kinds
of cool things they're going to be doing
for the next couple of days but I wanted
to go through some of the gear that I
brought because a lot of you guys are
always asking what I take with me when I
travel on trips because it's always a
lot of gear it's usually very heavy and
to be completely honest with you I
hardly ever use everything that I bring
but every time I don't bring something
it's the time that I actually need it so
let's go through the first thing that I
want to show you is I got this
specifically for this trip I've always
wanted to get a gimbal so what I got
it's a Zion green tube because it can
hold up to I think 7 pounds so I figure
if I have a heavy lens plus the body
plus a microphone pack potentially could
easily be 7 pounds so I got that one I'm
most excited about the Ronin s but I
don't know when that's gonna be out and
I need something in the meantime
especially III coming up and a bunch of
other events so I got the Zion crane and
if you guys have ever seen these things
I thought it was gonna be a little bit
smaller so the expectation versus
reality it just came in right before I
left this trip I didn't even have time
to do an unboxing I had to take out half
of my clothes another backpack yeah
Franchesca got me this for my birthday
isn't this the most beautiful thing
you've ever seen
Gela look oh you are kidding no I wasn't
kidding this is half of my suitcase I
tried to take it out of the case but I
wanted it to be protected especially
since I just got it
haven't even set it up I haven't done
anything yet did you like I'm not
carrying anything I think I probably
should have a smaller one moving along I
mean first I had to do some rearranging
because I was gonna try to only bring
one backpack and it didn't work
cuz I'm coming to camera camp I thought
I'm gonna want to bring some lenses but
of course the first thing that we've got
here is a movie charger this is the USBC
one which I usually specifically use for
charging my Samsung Galaxy I've been
using the s9 the lilac and of course the
micro 10 in these little side pockets
over on this side this always gets
flagged by TSA hey this is Samsonite
microphone this just folds down just
like so and then folds right back up so
also in this bag I've got this is a
tripod that goes to windy instance 60
cameras here's one of the Joby tripods I
just started using this one because if
I'm vlogging with heavier lenses I do
need to have something else that I can
hold on to so this works a little bit
better than the smaller Manfrotto ones
that I'm always using since we're a
camera cam I last a minute decided that
I was gonna bring some more lenses this
is the this oh this is a 16 to 35 I love
this lens because it is a wide-angle
lens but I can also get a little bit of
zoom and the other one that I brought
this one is a fixed lens this is the 18
millimeter this is a Zeiss this is what
I used to always vlog with but the
problem is you couldn't get a new zoom
so basically you have this 18 millimeter
and that's it so I really am interested
to test out the one that I'm using right
now this is one of the frontal ones that
I got from the event that we're at so
we'll see you see how it looks I know
the Lighting's not the best but it's the
best that I could do in our cabin hotel
situation this is the a7 3 I got this
new little neck strap for it it's one of
the ones that have the quick release so
you can just go
moderately quick release so if I'm
vlogging sometimes or going to be using
the gimbal I wanted to be able to easily
strap I wanted to easily be able to
combat this is the microphone that I
used on all of these cameras it's
actually saying microphone use now it's
this little Sony one and it's great
because you don't have to use any cords
or any audio input it uses the hot shoe
so it automatically just works basically
like magic and the lens that I'm using
one here this isn't a full frame lens
but with the a7 3 with the crop factor
this will automatically adjust you can
use this lens with this camera and I
love it because it's an inexpensive lens
and it gets the job done from blogging
and it makes this camera super super
light now we're gonna move on to my
little suitcase here depending upon what
a venom going to or I don't know where
I'm traveling to I do pack differently
but most of these things are pretty much
everything that I would normally bring
with me anyway usually I won't bring his
main lenses I'll just bring one or two
so here we've got my laptop in here here
are all of the die on crane accessories
that I couldn't put in my checked
luggage I like to keep one bag easily
accessible with all of my hard drives
and things that I might need if I'm
editing on the plane so I have a bunch
of this PC cables that I use for my hard
drives these are the same son solo state
drives these are each two terabytes I
basically edit all of my footage off of
these so I can switch between my macbook
and then editing on my mac pro so if i'm
editing on my macbook while traveling
and you just pop one of these into my
mac pro and export and it's so much
quicker and then i have a 4 terabyte
LaCie drive i usually use this just to
back up any footage in case something
happens
and of course our dongle this is a
little LED light this is actually the
same light that I'm using right here
beautiful Nick was the first one to ever
tell us about these and now Jenna and I
have been absolutely obsessed it comes
in this cute little bag charges with
micro USB and it even has some filters
and it's got like a little mount on it -
we got the DJI Mavic air this has been
my favorite drone as of recently it's
super small it's super compact and the
best part about it is the controller the
little joysticks those come off so it's
so much easier to travel with beautiful
drone feel like I keep everything very
very separate and in little tiny bags
this is my Sony rx100 mark 5 battery
charger this is a third-party one here's
the number 5 yes I know it's unrealistic
that I'm going to be able to use all of
these cameras at the same time but the
one time that I'll bring one you need it
I like to travel with a mouse I had been
recently traveling with a PC as well
because generating 24 tonight so we had
been playing on the PCs so I was using
ask Razer gaming mouse and we have this
little incase bag this is where I keep
all my wires and cables charging bricks
this is basically the battery bag we've
got the GoPro charger we've got a bunch
of cables listen up Apple watch charger
dongles gizmos a-plenty this here is my
DJI Mavic charger also separates
everything has a home my entire life is
usually in disarray but I could promise
you when I'm traveling everything has a
place
I look good you're probably I want to
zoom in now and post yeah can't see
that's my one complain about Sony is you
gotta get a flip-out screen already you
can zoom but I can't see myself so you
got two more tripods I've got this
little Manfrotto one I've also got this
little
[Music]
this is a funny story because I actually
thought that I was ordering this and
this is what I got now this is kind of
insane because the amount of stuff that
I have fit inside of this is absurd when
you guys see inside of this you're gonna
be like in here I've got this little
tiny portion up here that has actual
batteries so I have like triple a
double-a and the charging cables for the
new a 7-3 batteries which are much
bigger than the previous versions so got
these dual battery chargers which have
been really great because I'm able to
charge two at the same time so I've got
two of those taken charge basically a
four of them at the same time and if I
need to charge the extra one that's in
this camera right now I can do that with
a micro USB this is the instant 360 one
camera I'm obsessed with it it's just
been so much fun I'll be doing a
separate video over that sometime soon
I've also got the Mavic air batteries in
here this is also the dock that goes
with that the batteries go right here
and the controller nicely fits in here I
also got another lens this is the power
zoom lens that I was telling the guys
about before this is the 18 to 105 and
becomes the power zoom lens I love this
because we need it perfect for the
gimbal because you won't have the line
moving
Kimbrel off balance I also brought a
GoPro a holster brought the rx0 it took
me so long to pack today because I went
through and had to reorganize everything
from my previous trip I think that's
pretty much everything that I brought to
this trip will I use it all probably not
but I'm so excited for this event it's
gonna be really fun
you have a little nice name tag get mine
yet well I will or you wouldn't ruder
Ivan intruder you don't belong here well
I will see you guys later thanks for
coming along for this little gear travel
tour I just wanted to do a quick little
video to show you guys what I'm
traveling with because sometimes people
don't realize how much actually goes
into making YouTube videos can we try
the lens out oh gosh
do any question hi done wow this is you
know what it yeah like I only have a few
little things bright pretzels
[Music]
[Applause]